I'm PN we also have garrett another one
of my colleagues in the software
engineering department and then over
there we have Brett yeah and we have
bread haynes here who is also another
engineer on the team he works primarily
with the Raspberry Pi port works on some
of our other emerging devices okay so
let's get started all right okay so
we're going to start with the topic of
an introduction to the Internet of
Things so how many people here are
familiar with the term Internet of
Things how many people feel like you
actually understand what they mean by
internet of things okay all right that's
that's alright that's alright I'm going
to go out and say it this is an
extremely hand-wavy topic in the tech
industry it's nebulous and it's pretty
ill do it's pretty poorly defined but
for our purposes what we kind of are
thinking about with Internet of Things
is consumer sensor networks basically
you know little devices that are
delivering data to some sort of hub you
know and data analytics with that hub
and it's also sort of a you know
mainstream Linux devices largely fall
under the Internet of Things banner so
the Raspberry Pi the Arduino Intel
Edison you know any device that
basically puts embedded like computing
into the hands of you know regular users
you know who are not you know doing
system integration or having like a
million devices produced in you know
shenzhen or something like that that is
that is it that is in the Internet of
Things umbrella and if you can hold it
in your hand and it can connect to some
sort of network it's part you can
probably call it Internet of Things
right so that's basically you know what
what it refers to things like you know
motors machines sensors you know weather
stations and you know things connecting
to the internet and delivering data and
it kind of like another thing about the
Internet of Things that I think a lot of
people kind of forget about is that it's
not just all of these different devices
bringing data into the system there's
also the application of when you get
that data you analyze that you figure
out what's going on and then you like
put stuff out so a typical example would
be like you know
but the example that I've heard a lot is
case of like having sensors in the road
that can detect how much traffic is in
the city and stuff and so if you have a
large metropolitan area and say there's
some giant pile up on you know I 74 or
something and you know traffic is just
terrible in that part of the city the
sensors could report some central you
know station that hey this part of the
city is experiencing lots of traffic and
then based on that you know you could re
route bus routes or something and kind
of do something with that so it's not
just about getting all this data and
analyzing it there's also like the
output of it so you get all the data is
input analyze it then there's output as
well right so there's you know there's
different directions Internet of Things
goes in there's the reading aggregating
the data then there's the doing yep you
know and a lot of our demos we have some
demos here that are focused on reading
data putting data into the kernel and
recording that data and we've got some
demos focused on just doing things using
the colonel using Mathematica the wolfer
mention to actually do things on your
end of things devices and those tasks
are somewhat distinct from each other
yeah yeah and and one of the really
powerful things that the wolf that
Wolfram engine and the kernel of
mathematica bring to the situation is
the powerful data analysis that's made
really really simple so one of the other
kind of caveats that's kind of
preventing the Internet of Things from
like really taking off is that it's
really difficult for people to get all
this data together and then meaningfully
analyze it right because there's a lot
of you know a lot of people with you
know high paying jobs who are like data
scientists and they know all about all
these kinds of statistical methods and
all you know this complicated stuff that
they can do but there's a lot of
consumer people who would like to get
into this but they don't necessarily
have that background and so Mathematica
and the Wolfram language bring to the
equation the ability to like really
rapidly start to analyze this data and
understand data sets in inside
Mathematica right and the thing to think
about is the Internet of Things produces
a lot of noise it produces a lot of
noise and it produces a lot of very
complicated data in large volume because
when you're actually looking at what's
coming out of a sensor what's coming out
of you know some sort of smart device
what you're really talking about is
dream of numbers a stream of numbers
that looked at without context are just
going to be you know you know random
data feed and you know one of the things
I think that we bring to the table and
one of the things that we want to focus
on is turning data into you know time
device think you know time series and
quantities you know things that are
actually physical quantities that can be
read and understood by our software as
quantities yeah one another like so we
have met desktop Mathematica that you
can use to analyze this stuff but
there's also Wolfram Alpha and the
interpretation and like the interpreter
engine that powers Wolfram Alpha all of
that works and so if you have something
like you know say you have I don't know
some sort of sensor that's reporting
back I don't know what the unit dollars
or something you can use interpreter
functions and so you can say interpreter
of currency amount and then it's just
applied to like I don't know two dollars
and then and so it makes it really easy
so the result that we get back here is
an actual like unit and so interpreter
is able to kind of rapidly apply
semantic analysis to really figure out
what's you know hiding behind the data
right and just to take chores out of
dealing with data just dealing with data
and quantities because I mean I think
there was an instance what like a few
years ago where I think NASA actually
crashed a probe on account of a
conversion error between metric and
traditional conversions and I mean yeah
exactly but you know creating those
additional those additional chores as
additional steps and things people just
need to think about an account for you
know just adds complexity to the task of
dealing with data and dealing with
quantities so one of the you know up
shots to our high-level quantity objects
is that you can interact with them in
any format you choose to yeah yeah and
so and so these units aren't just like a
little tooltip thing you can actually so
we could say let me scroll down here no
that's okay but you can use functions
like unit converts of I can just take
this unit right here and I don't know
what's a what's a non US currency
someone
euros all right cool euro sent there we
go heroes and so that and so you can
just like rapidly apply all these
different things you don't have to worry
about Oh am I using the most up-to-date
trading things because it's all powered
by Wolfram Alpha and all like just gobs
and gobs of people are it's their job to
bring data into wolfram alpha and but we
care more about the fixed units in this
case because as much as Intel might not
like and in qualcomm might not like it
the devices do not print money so yes
yes there's our own the currency
conversion is perhaps not the most
relevant yes but a thing here but so
let's move on to the all right so
Internet of Things and i would i'm just
going to encourage you guys up front if
you guys have any questions about
anything just let us know yeah you know
we're gonna add as we go we're not
separating this into a Q&A section if
there's anything that we're being
unclear about or anything you'd like
clarification on just raise your hand
and we'll go into it okay go ahead
alright so one of the really powerful
things that Wolfram has relating to
Internet of Things is a thing called
data drop how many people are familiar
with or views data drop at all okay so a
few people what really makes data drop
powerful how I describe it is like drop
boxes for your files data drop is for
your data and so data drop when you put
data into it it logs like when that data
was put in like what kind of data and
you can look at all sorts of time series
the it logs lots of metadata about the
data it makes analysis of that data very
simple and intuitive and so it's very
easy to create so in data drop you have
like the storage things are called data
bins and so you can just use functions
like create data bin right and while
while Ian goes ahead and fills in his
credentials there I'll talk a little bit
about the importance of metadata for
data collection and one of the most
important things you can get with data
collection is a time stamp because a lot
of data that you capture is going to be
in some ways it takes place in the
physical world and whereas you know we
work in the symbolic world here where
you know we try to avoid side effects
over possible the world of sensors in
the world of physical devices is all
side effects and there is a
you know there is often times you will
want to do some analysis of your data
after you've collected it and you might
say have a have a sensor outside that's
recording you know some sort of value
like humidity or something like that and
then you might realize that your
measurement is inaccurate when it's
taken at a certain temperature so you
might look at the temperature data or
you might look at you know data on the
weather after the fact and then use that
those that metadata to you know do some
additional filtering of your data
afterwards and you know adjust the
collection that you've done based on the
time yeah exactly so data drive makes it
really easy to create a location for
these and then we can easily add to it
there are multiple different ways it
have been add so i just take this data
bin and whoops almost got away there
yeah i tried to get away from me so you
can add to the data bin in here I don't
know that's just add no two volts or
something and now that will get added to
the data bin and now you see that the
entry count is one obviously it's really
easy to add data right from Mathematica
but one of the powerful things about
data drop is that we also have like a
full REST API you can add it through the
web form there's lots of different ways
to add this from things outside the
Wolfram language so in lots of lots of
times you have devices like the
raspberry pi or an arduino eun or
something that isn't running Mathematica
or it doesn't make sense for
mathematical be running there and it's
still easy to add data to the to the
data bin from that chip by just making
simple HTTP rest you know calls and
stuff and so it's really easy to bring
data into data drop that's you know
right in a lot of cases it just doesn't
make sense to run the current to run the
actual colonel to do something if you're
just you have a simple device that you
know runs using like you know tiny
amount of power you know sitting up on a
tree somewhere taking taking collection
you don't want to incur the penalty of
you know running you know workstation
class software just in order to make
that recording and record it somewhere
you want that workstation class software
in the you know to be doing analytics
and we like our capability of doing
you know analytics on you know devices
that are more of full computers like the
Raspberry Pi but you don't necessarily
need them to collect 80 and work with it
yeah exactly so yeah so data drop makes
it really easy to bring data into into
like a centralized location you can
analyze it and then using the Wolfram
language and mathematica or wolfram
desktop or the Wolfram cloud because
right you can access all this stuff from
any of our products like that makes it
really easy to do perform statistical
analysis and analyze all that data like
we're talking about it's kind of key to
Internet of Things is filtering out the
noise so it's really easy to do that
kind of thing in Mathematica but that's
kind of the topic of another talk all
the data analysis so okay next one
you're right so arduino is like kind of
one of our first like big devices that
we want to kind of push as an Internet
of Things device because what what the
Arduino brings to the equation well
first an Arduino is for those who are
unaware is it's a small electronics
platform I have one here there's one
over there it's a what makes the Arduino
specifically really powerful because
there are lots of similar devices to
Arduino is the open source community
behind Arduino and all of the effort or
the time and effort that people put into
developing physical hardware to
interface with it but also the software
that powers that and so so so there's
the hardware aspect so there's lots of
devices like you know sensor shields for
reading stuff like temperature humidity
there's also really obscure shields like
I don't know measuring co2 or measuring
some sort of gas or chemistry stuff
there's all kinds of physical sensors
you can use that have been like you know
physically handmade for the Arduino I
have an example one over here this is a
vernis a if people are familiar with the
company Bernier they make sensors for
like high school or college level
classes and so this is a little shield
that Bernier makes that plugs right into
the Arduino that you can then take a you
know device like I have here a force
sensor and plug it into the shield and
then you can use it
with an Arduino so there are lots of
there's lots of devices like that that
people or companies have developed to
make it easy to connect all sorts of
physical devices with with the Arduino
so that's kind of the hardware aspect
and then on the software side there's
also like tons and tons of libraries and
C and C++ that people have developed for
interfacing with these devices that make
it you know they make it so that you
don't have to be an electrical engineer
or computer scientist who have you know
to interface with the devices you know i
frightened two lines of code you can
just you know use one library it makes
it simple and an important thing to talk
about with when we bring up the Arduino
it may seem a little bit
counterintuitive that we have these very
different strategies for arduino and
then devices like a raspberry PI's and
beagle bones and other sort of Linux
boards that you see you know things that
can actually run Mathematica and you
might wonder what what's the distinction
here and it has a lot to do with time
and the explanation is basically the
Raspberry Pi is about as powerful as a
desktop workstation from the mid 90s you
know to late 90s depending on the model
that you have and a Arduino really has
the computational power of like I don't
know a Nintendo a Commodore 64 or like a
wristwatch kind of oh yeah it has like
one purpose and one simple thing that
you can upload and tell it to do and it
just does that right but but what's
useful about it is that whereas like you
have a full fledge operating system and
you can do all sorts of stuff like run
Mathematica or web browsers and stuff on
a Raspberry Pi that also brings with a
lot of overhead and that it's you know
there's stuff that you don't need so if
i'm just reading from a simple
temperature sensor or something i can
just plug it right into the arduino and
i don't have to worry about any of the
other stuff i don't have to worry about
like multi-threading stuff or like you
know linux deciding that it wants to
prioritize libre office or something
instead of my sensor application you
know whatever there's just the program i
upload to the arduino and that's just
what runs right so time is absolute on a
microcontroller you know you have a
fixed problem that you're solving you
know it is running a certain set of
instructions and that it's all it is
doing so in a system where time is
critical you're
and you're going to find yourself
wanting to use in arduino arduinos are
also useful versus the Raspberry Pi
specifically and that they have analog
pins yep and you need analog pins if
you're going to be interacting with
things like motors right yeah I mean
anything where you know you're sending a
certain amount of like voltage or you're
trying to drive a motor or drive wheels
or something like that you'd attempt to
do that sort of stuff with a raspberry
pi and you're really quickly going to
find yourself with a burned-out
Raspberry Pi yeah because it's the
margin of error is slim yeah yeah
exactly and so and so how Mathematica
kind of comes into this is there's a
device driver in Mathematica since
Mathematica 10.1 that allows you to to
not only just read it right to these
pins on the Arduino so you'll take the
Arduino and like physically plug in the
USB cable and then you know plug it into
your computer and then you can start
reading from it reading from the pins
and writing to the pins but there's also
the more complicated and I think cooler
application of it is you can deploy
arbitrary functions to the Arduino and
execute them so this is a situation
where you have some complicated sensor
that has a library that somebody wrote
for it you know like on the open on you
know the Arduino forums or somebody in
like a here's this library they wrote
that library and so using that library
it's really easy to interface with that
device so what you can do in Mathematica
is you can deploy that library and
deploy a simple function that just uses
that library to the Arduino and then you
can call that code from within
Mathematica and then it will return back
to you whatever the result is so instead
of having to write all of your code from
scratch and like you know symbolic c or
something you just write a short little
snippet of code and see your C++ and
then deploy that to the Arduino and you
can call that and bring that data right
in into mathematica right so all right
now the Raspberry Pi now the Raspberry
Pi is the cheapest the cheapest way to
get your hands on the Wolfram language
it is the it is the lowest end device
that we target for for you know for
Mathematica and it also is a little bit
different but you know it's so it's a
very low-end device but what makes it
distinct from a pc is it has these very
raw interfaces it has things like GPIO
pins on it it has the ability to
directly interact with hardware with
lights and things like that you probably
can do that with a PC but you need a
special card or board might just be a
bad idea honestly but you know people
like so the Raspberry Pi is also useful
if you know you need to do some sort of
you need some sort of intelligence in
your application I think it's not
uncommon actually to keep a tit for a
Raspberry Pi and an Arduino to be used
together you know the Arduino might
drive some sort of physical system like
motors or you know handle some sort of
reading in the Raspberry Pi may simply
be running a simple program yeah read
this data make a simple decision I'm
going to continuously read this value
and when it reaches a certain
temperature maybe I'll send a message I
can send an email i can send a tweet you
mean for to buy that are you talking
about like the availability of sensors
to interface probably the Arduino just
because Arduino as Alex was kind of
saying has more of like a raw interface
and that you can have analog values in
putting and so it's much more likely
that you'll find just kind of fringe
sensors are made in and you might have
heard me mention the word shield but a
shield specifically means it's like
somebody made a board that physically
plugs into into the Arduino so like it
just physically plugs into that and you
don't have to worry about wiring or
anything else right I would say that
another thing to consider too is whether
you see your solution being largely
tethered to your PC or whether you want
that to be something that's deployed
independently and has this independent
life cycle because there is additional
overhead in integrating a solution with
a raspberry pi and that you have a full
computer requires more power requires
you know some additional configuration
probably configuring things like
networking and stuff like that you know
in order to get in order to get it
working but the more advanced
application is probably going to be
built on the Raspberry Pi or you know
with a Raspberry Pi in Arduino in
conjunction because it can act as a host
for the Arduino so but it's a
complicated topic as well because the
Raspberry Pi is also a PC it's also a
small pc and it's really you know I
think it's often people might think of
this is like an embedded board because
it looks like a board but it's really a
small computer and you know one of the
other use cases of the Wolfram language
on Raspberry Pi is just using it as a
very low-end desktop for you know
purpose of Education they're just
exploration yeah I mean the other thing
about the raspberry pi is it's only I
think $35 now yeah yeah I mean you can
buy a Raspberry Pi for thirty-five
dollars and it has you know you find
your own keyboard and mouse and monitor
and you have a fully working computer
that you can use so so that's why it's
really important or really widely used
in education because it's so easy to
access our to get resources to interface
with this instead of having to spend
like you know five or six hundred
dollars I'm like a dell computer and
monitor and stuff you just get the
monitor or you could even use like a
normal TV because as hdmi and then get
your Raspberry Pi for thirty-five
dollars and bam you got a computer so
alright so okay that's the actual that's
the last slide that we had you want to
want to show your force sensor sure okay
so once too little bit of show-and-tell
yeah so one application let me so right
now with the Arduino functionality that
we have the the current board that we
support is Arduino Uno so there's all
these different Arduino boards there's
like one with Bluetooth there's one with
Wi-Fi one with like just this but the
standard Arduino board is just an
arduino uno and it doesn't have any of
this more complicated stuff you just
plug it in and you can start using it
the arduino you and however and that's
actually what I've been showing here has
like an additional coprocessor on it
that has Wi-Fi capabilities and so you
can interact with it over Wi-Fi so let
me yeah essentially it's a device that
runs linux so it has a full operating
system on it
and can be interacted with as a computer
but it's very important to note it is in
a class between the microcontroller and
the Raspberry Pi this thing can not and
will never run the Wolfram language but
when we interact with it we interact
with it as a bear linux device yep and
so the application about to show I just
got up my phone to turn on tethering so
I have a Wi-Fi password because some of
the other Wi-Fi in here is a little
unreliable but so I have Wi-Fi from my
phone and now I'm going to connect the
laptop to Wi-Fi but first before I do
that I'm going to first set up the the
UN so I just plug it in here and now i
can use device open and the device
framework to open a connection to this
device I'll here let me reopen it here
so we open up that connection now
there's a connection to the Arduino
Union and whoops hang on a second
so here we go okay there we go so now
it's uploading to the Arduino Union and
it's going to program that with a sketch
that will basically via Wi-Fi talk back
to the laptop and all right there we go
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to physically disconnect it from my
normal computer over here and I'll plug
it into an external battery I have so
there's nothing else connected here it
takes about 60 seconds for it to start
up so I just have a little timer here
just run wait for it to start back up in
the meantime one of the things that I
want to kind of talk about right now is
the device framework how many people
have heard the device framework or know
what it is arnoud all right great okay
so device framework is a new feature in
mathematica 10 that's kind of a way for
you to interface with a way for you to
write your own kind of drivers and
there's ones that are included in
language as well to interface with
devices basically so it's kind of an
object-oriented kind of thing you have
device objects and you have device
classes if we go back up here to device
open you see that that returns a device
object and there are various things you
can let query about the Vice objects
they have properties and such and sort
of a symbolic reference symbolic
reference to a device exactly exactly
let's make sure I'm on the same Wi-Fi
network I am NOT I need to get on the
other Wi-Fi network okay cool all right
so um wait a few more seconds for this
to finish on some 80 second timer it is
that is a pre-coffee 60-second timer
right there yes I gave myself a little
bit of extra time because yeah but ok ok
I think and the other thing I just want
a quick show is so I have this this
camera here I'll turn it on just a
second but this is another device that
you can read from in the Wolfram
language you can just use device read
actually you can do find a device as
another I want to make this a little bit
bigger people read this
can run find device's camera so there's
two there's the webcam on this laptop
and then there's also this yeah I'm okay
I'll get in a second if you want to find
that so we can open that device the
camera device by just using device open
of the device object and then we can
read from that so we can do device read
from hope it wasn't a very exciting
image but what it basically it's
basically you know reading from the
camera there you go so if we want to
make this a live feed we can just say
dynamic at device camera as soon as it
decides to load that so you can see ooh
okay maybe maybe that was maybe that was
a little too ambitious a little
ambitious there okay well should we get
our camper yeah yeah let me just delete
this and oh sure sure so with a camera I
believe I believe dynamic knows that
when you use it with a device framework
thing it knows that it should update
that yeah it's a special case for
dynamic
so so actually one thing that I kind of
mentioned at my arduino talk this
morning is that interface dynamic how
kind of internal implementation of that
is that it uses like a special front-end
evaluator and so it can kind of like
jump in behind the actual colonel that's
running and that isn't exactly the best
because the colonel like knows how to
interface with the i/o device and notice
you know to notice how to handle it and
not send it like a million requests and
a half a second it dynamic there's
special things that that dynamic has
that make it work that way but yeah I
believe specifically the dynamic of a
camera is a special case as an
explicitly special case I think that is
ok set up to work that way ok so let me
yeah question should i don't I thought
we had we had also see that this will be
on the table we should i think you know
we have an advanced section after this
we can just crack open some device are
some of the device drivers in the layout
and actually show them to you if you're
interested alright so what is going to
demo with arduino union is so i can run
device read of arduino and that will
talk via Wi-Fi to that chip so you can
see you know various analog pins are in
units of voltage and down here i have a
nice little dynamic of the current value
of the analog pin and so when i plug my
vernis a shield into the here
alright so it stabilizes about 2.5 volts
and the force sensor that i have
attached here when I pull on it hey the
voltage goes down if i push on it the
voltage goes up and again all of this is
like completely over the quality that
wirelessly like this all over Wi-Fi
network connections Sonny no yes the
strings are the strings aren't gone now
we are we are fully wireless yes so I
was just going to demo you know this is
a five-pound weight that we're lifting
up so if we were to run can you just run
device read of here eight ok plenty
gonna run the code ok well you have a
mic in your hands I guess yeah this is
more my skill set here yes ok so I'm
just going to run device read of Arduino
and then I'm going to read a zero so
that's at one point 6 volts so we can
convert that to a we can use the units
to convert you can put it down now so if
we multiply that result by let's see if
I remember the conversion factor so the
so this specific device is what's called
a ratiometric device which means that in
the middle that's zero at the top that's
like half the distance at the bottom
that's like you know the minimum and
this is a plus or minus 50 Newtons so it
has a range of 100 Newton's over 5 volts
so if we just use control equals and we
say 100 Newtons and then that gets
interpreted as a unit hopefully yep
there we go and we can divide that by
another unit of 5 volts and so you can
see how instead of having to type in all
these complicated stuff to use units you
can just press control equals and then
type in normal english language so so
that's the conversion between Newton's
25 volts but then it's ratiometric so it
starts at two and a half full so we have
to add two and a half volts to that
first to get that conversion so sad or
actually i'll subtract right
alright and so if we multiply everything
by that oh you don't need to use the
checkboxes fine so that's negative so
let me just multiply that by what
negative 1 so so that's how much that
weighs in Newtons and if we wanted to
like confirm that we could convert it to
pounds force so we take a unit convert
of let's just do that again and we do
pounds force for that I might have
gotten the conversion ratio slightly off
I don't think it's exactly 5 volts but
it's supposed to be a five-pound weight
it's like 3.74 pounds so there's some
error in my conversion factor here but
they look close enough for off the cuff
it's close enough exactly close enough
for off the cuff science so but but yeah
what we just wanted to show is that you
can interface with the device or this is
a new feature that will be coming into
probably Mathematica 11 the support for
the Arduino Yoon and wireless arduino
stuff and you know while we're not
totally accurate here just imagine doing
this in see it's a little bit more of a
pain and so you know that's that's yeah
what the end the quantity units bring to
it and imagine doing that and see
question the dynamic so so the setup so
when I initially ran the setup up here
where I run it the device configure of
deploy that deploys the sketch that was
when i had it physically plugged into
the computer right and so when you run
that sketch what it does is it deploys a
sketch to figure out like the Wi-Fi
configuration info and then that gets
saved inside the device driver and then
that's how the device driver knows what
IP address to talk to stuff like that
yeah i mean you manually set the
information the network information
correct yeah i mean i set up the arduino
union previously what we want to
eventually do is we want to have options
to device open so that you can just buy
the arduino moon take it out of the
package plug it in and then you put in
your network options into device open
and then it would set all that up that
takes a little bit longer and so I just
manually set that up before
and then this just gets the IP address
dynamically right so it's I mean we're
not we haven't released yet yeah well do
that when you we release it exactly yeah
and then these are just some histograms
that I made of the reading times and so
you can see this is pretty good for for
network communication these are in units
of seconds so I'm would so when I did
this for 100 readings a majority of them
were less than point 1 seconds to get
the response time pack so so yeah in
digital writing was even more so
actually I could quick show open up
presenter this still feed did you oh
there we go do you want to oh yeah if
you could point it at the yeah so so not
just can you do dynamic reading you can
also do writing let me here's an example
this is not should should we put out of
the IP evil over it yeah how you can do
that quick sure we'll try to make this
visible to you guys so
this is a relatively advanced example of
using a raspberry pi and arduino to to
do to work with to work on a particular
solution this was a a robot that's
essentially designed to draw popular
curves so it's basically Garrett Garrett
could you give a brief explanation of
the robot so the robot has a couple
different parts so we start with a
notebook just Wolfram notebook on the
computer that communicates with Wolfram
on the Raspberry Pi so using the
notebook on the computer we can watch
essentially a Wolfram Colonel instance
on the Raspberry Pi which then can run
different functions as a remote Colonel
on the Raspberry Pi from there we'll use
the Raspberry Pi to use some similar
functions that heated and device
configure the Arduino with the path that
we want in order to draw the character
that we have so I have a couple
characters here that I do earlier in a
moment hopefully I can get this working
if there's a video feed so yeah you just
hold it okay oh great thank you okay so
so basically what the Wolfram kernel is
doing on the Raspberry Pi is its
generating a custom program that
includes the instructions required to do
this drawing basically a set of
movements for the wheels you know that
will there's a pen attached to it that
will basically draw the picture
okay so there's a few different systems
at play here in this demo we have number
one the Raspberry Pi running the Wolfram
language kernel and then we have his
desktop laptop over there also running
Wolfram language and those two are
connected via a thing called launch
manager which is a new thing that will
be coming out it's another upcoming
another update feature do you want to
talk about launch manager just briefly
so basically the functionality we're
going to be providing especially for
remote devices like that is if anyone's
ever used bon jour printer support you
know the basically the the technology
that you know Macintosh is used to find
an Apple TV and something like that it's
called you know zeroconf or mdns we've
set up an agent that can run on you know
that could run on a device and basically
advertise the Colonel's available on
that device so if you're on the same
local area network you can just discover
any other available kernels on that and
it make it really simplifies the process
of connecting to a remote device it's as
easy as just find it and then open it up
and you have a remote connection to to
that device I believe if anyone was that
a Roman mater's talk I think it would
actually happen anyone I know okay so
you're missing Roman manners talk about
about that exact technology but it I
will be coming in a future release yep
so so we have the two kernels to
somebody of a question oh okay so we
have the two kernels running we have one
in the raspberry pi 1 a desktop
Mathematica that are talking via by the
network configuration and then we also
have the Arduino on board try and show
well maybe not you know it an Arduino
looks like by now but is that the
Arduino is hooked up to the Raspberry Pi
and the Raspberry Pi is talking to the
Arduino using the Arduino device driver
and the Arduino is then itself hooked up
to all the motors and physical stuff
that actually you know makes the robot
move and do stuff like draw so that kind
of just showcases all of the different
systems that we have available that you
can use we did not include data drop
because when we built this we're
planning to not not have internet
connectivity at the location we were
first demoing at maker faire
so we did not include but it would have
been very easy to add data bin you know
we could use data drop to upload to a
data bin you know which which direction
it was facing or he could added some
sort of sensor on it right the robot
could have just been instagramming
everything it did yeah exactly very
easily if it had a reliable internet
connection yes we are we were doing it
at at a event and it tends to be
internet connectivity is questionable at
events